so right now a lot of people are really
focusing on what's going to happen in
Avengers 4 obviously and it's for a good
reason because we really have no idea
what's going to happen in Avengers 4 but
every now and then we get a few comments
from somebody at Marvel about what's
going to happen after Avengers 4 before
we get into the interview with Kevin
Feige don't forget about the giveaway
I'm giving away a few copies of Avengers
infinity war on blu-ray all you have to
do to enter is be subscribed to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your favorite superhero so in
a recent interview with Costco
connection Kevin Feige was asked about
what happens when some of the actors are
ready to move on
Costco connections said you talked about
how the characters have changed in the
10 years what happens when the actors
who created them are ready to move on in
which Kevin Feige replied that's what we
can look to in the comics and that's why
these characters are so relevant I
talked about 10 years of movies but it's
50 plus years of these characters in the
comics and they are just as relevant and
popular and that's because they do get
updated they do change but the times I
have no doubt that all of our actors who
are in peak physical shape have got
another 50 years in them to be heroes in
terms of the specifics of how we will
evolve the characters thankfully I don't
have to really think about it yet
because we're still finishing what we
started here with Avengers infinity war
I love that he says they're going to
look to the comics because it does give
sort of a great base to go off of even
if they don't really follow the comics a
hundred percent which they really don't
there's still a lot of really good
stories to get ideas from mantels get
passed down in the comics ultimately
these actors won't be able to play these
characters forever and at some point in
time whether that's right after Avengers
4 or 10 years down the road they're
gonna have to come to an end you kid
well you one sandwich away from fat yeah
right and even though Kevin Feige says
he's not really looking past Avengers 4
right now I think we all know that he is
obviously they have Captain Marvel
coming out right before Avengers 4 they
have spider-man far
homecoming out as well so they are
thinking a little bit into the future at
least there's a few characters whose
contracts are coming up but that doesn't
necessarily mean anything they can
always be given new contracts but it's
just nice to know that when the time
does come they have a plan a rage and
vengeance anger loss regret there'll
tremendous motive they just they really
clear the mind so honey I'm good to go
and not about one at all because there
are truly some amazing storylines in the
comics so what do you all think about
Kevin Feige comments on replacing actors
in the MCU let me know your thoughts in
the comments below and again don't
forget about the giveaway I'll be giving
away a few copies of Avengers infinity
war on blu-ray all you have to do is be
subscribed to my channel like this video
and comment below with your favorite
superhero thank you all so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]
you